hi BBI students so today we're gonna
look at the the topic of cardiovascular
disease or CVD which forms as part of
the topic of topic 5 on house and
disease and the specification point that
gets covered here is knowing so
describing exactly how the process of
the of the condition is formed within
the body and how that happen happens
through a number of interaction of
different factors which which occurs
within the body so that in a separate
question or even a separate video you
will be able to look at the good and the
disadvantages of some of the treatments
of the disease okay
so we're just going to start on looking
at how this condition forms in the body
and it's quite important to know about
this topic because it affects quite a
large number of people in the UK it's a
condition that affects the arteries of
the blood vessels and so I always like
to remember that artery starts with an A
and away starts with an A as well so
that's how I couldn't remember that it's
affecting the blood vessels which is a
set essentially taking the blood away
from the heart okay so this happens due
to factors now some of these risk
factors we are able to manage ourselves
and we can change through living a more
healthy lifestyle but some of them are a
bit more permanent and not necessarily
something we can do about for example
our age or our gender are things that we
cannot change so the main thing really
that has an impact on the arteries is a
buildup of really bad highly saturated
cholesterol okay and those tend to be
diets that are high in low-density
lipoproteins in within the food so that
LDL is that is the bad fat and HDL is
the good one okay so this cholesterol
will build up and what will happen as a
result of
lifestyle things sometimes we stress
okay alcohol would be another one that
would affect it so part of the unhealthy
diet also something like smoking would
have an impact on the blood vessel so
what would happen is all of these risk
factors would directly impact the artery
in this way so if this is the artery
here and the blood is flowing through
the artery
this way first of all the lining of the
it's called the endothelium first of all
the lining of the artery gets damaged
here so let's say we're experiencing
high stress or for example smoking this
will start having an impact on starting
to damage the artery wall here and then
on top of that if we start eating fatty
foods the cholesterol will then start to
deposit down in the artery okay so these
are called fatty deposits okay
over time this here just gets worse and
more and more fatty deposits will build
up and eventually we will also have
little bits of calcium that will start
to harden this area and once it's
reached that stage we call it a plaque
okay so first of all we've got this
damage here on the artery then the
cholesterol building up causing these
fatty deposits eventually we've got
calcium that forms the plaque and what
you'll notice is happening to we called
this this area here if I had a host bite
that area there of the host Viper I
would call that area the lumen of the
artery
so the
in here is getting more and more narrow
as this is building up so eventually the
blood is really going to struggle to get
through the artery now as we know that
our red blood cells are the cells that
carry oxygen they will really struggle
to get through to all of our main organs
for example to our heart and sometimes
also to our brain so that we really
struggle to get through and as a result
they will not be enough oxygen being
delivered to very crucial parts of our
body okay so if this eventually forms
such a big plaque that it starts forming
blood clots okay so no blood can no it
can no longer get through that's when we
have cardiovascular disease where this
can have directly impacted the heart and
cause a heart attack or sometimes this
clot that forms here can break free
travel to other parts of the of the
circulatory system and sometimes end up
in the brain and that's how we would get
a stroke okay so it's therefore very
important that we manage our lifestyle
factors in terms of these and make sure
that we get plenty of exercise okay so
that summarizes the topic of how
cardiovascular disease is caused and
you've had a look at the number of
different factors that will cause that